[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we turn
to something that somehow manages to be
so ludicrous that i had to spend about
30 minutes googling it just to make sure
that it wasn't some kind of joke or
parody
it is as it turns out no joke at least
not intentionally the washington free
beacon
reports on the news and i'll give you
some of the background before we get to
the really good stuff
reading from the free beacon report it
says top geologists condemned systemic
white supremacy in the field of
geoscience
which concerns the study of earth and
rocks in a manifesto published at the
scientific journal nature communications
the manifesto which was spearheaded by
fort hayes state university geology
professor
hendrada ali and signed by 20 academics
asserts that the lack of black
geologists demonstrates the bigoted
roots of the science
they called on colleagues to quash the
racist quote expectations around manners
clothing hair professional attire
language and diction
in an effort to boost diversity in the
field racism has led to the geosciences
becoming one of the least diverse among
all science and engineering fields
racism thrives in geoscience geoscience
organizes
organizations function alongside the
same racist ideologies and practices
shaping society so they're addressing
the lack of
black people in the field of geology
this is no doubt a problem that has
plagued your mind and
haunted your dreams i know that it has
for me i often wake up in a cold sweat
tossing and turning my eyes wet with
tears
my wife will turn to me and say well
what's wrong what's what is it
and i'll say there's not enough there's
not enough and she'll say not enough
what
black geologists we need more diversity
in the geological sciences
this happens like three times a week i'm
seeing a therapist about it
now it's good that the people who
publish this paper are finally dealing
with this problem but as i said
this is only the background we haven't
gotten to the real headline here and
before we do a little more from this
from this paper speaking in general
terms about the need for more
anti-racism education among those who
study rocks it says quote
in considering anti-racism in the
geosciences we cannot ignore the
intersex
intersecting identities of marginalized
people
we must acknowledge the added burden of
inequalities and oppression experienced
by people
and communities with these
intersectional identities such as black
women who are subjected to both sexism
and racism or when class status
disability gender expression or sexual
identity
intersects with other minoritized
identities
indeed focusing on only one axis of
diversity has led to some gains only in
more white women working as
geoscientists
but has not increased the participation
of bipoc
and other marginalized peoples okay
so this is your standard issue racial
grievance mongering so far
the grievance mongers have identitated
identified a certain
very specific area of society in this
case the field of geology
and decided arbitrarily that there
should be more black people involved in
it
and then they decided just as
arbitrarily that the lack of black
people
is due to racism it couldn't just be
that not as many black people feel like
studying rocks for a living
can't say i blame them no no it has to
be racism that's what it is
this is all as i said pretty standard
fair and then we get to this
listen very closely and this again is
real
access implies that individuals can
obtain the resources they need to safely
pursue their scientific endeavors
regardless of location instrumentation
site accessibility and their identity
historically access has been limited to
mostly able-bodied white cisgender
heterosexual men
as the geosciences strive to be more
accessible the community must recognize
that bipac and other marginalized
geoscientists
are not marginalized geoscientists
anyway other marginalized geoscientists
are not are not always safe
in geoscience spaces for example
holding objects for example a rock
hammer
has been viewed as suspicious and
continues to be used as a reason to call
the black to call the police on black
people
which can lead to the death of black
individuals entirely because of racial
profiling
and an unjustified fear of black people
okay
you heard that right geology is racist
because black people are afraid of
holding hammers
this makes me among other things feel
bad for the black cashier who rang up my
items at home depot last week
i mean imagine the psychological trauma
he must suffer on a daily basis
and why are black people afraid of
hammers well because if they hold one
somebody might call the cops and then
the cops will come and shoot them
in fact this is a problem we're told
with all physical objects in general
according to the paper
any activity that requires holding an
object of any kind
can be construed as racist because of
how it endangers black lives
you might not have known this but if you
have ever worked at say the concession
stand at a movie theater
and you handed a black customer his
large bucket of popcorn
after he paid for it um you just put his
life in jeopardy
somebody should have come and smacked
that popcorn out of your hands and said
no
don't do that you're gonna kill this man
are you doing that's an object he can't
hold an object
i mean you should know better honestly
than to go around giving objects to
people of color
it is your unique privilege as a white
person to hold objects
other races of people don't have that
ability they just don't
now um you may ask
many questions um such as
has there ever been a case has there
ever been a case
ever in history even once of a black
geologist being shot by the cops
for using a hammer to break open some
rocks
the paper would seem to indicate that
this is an epidemic i know it's not an
epidemic i'm just wondering
has it ever happened at all at any point
since the inception of the field of
geology
has any geologist of any color or race
been killed by the police in the course
of their duty
for using a hammer
and by the way if geology excludes black
people because of how it requires the
use of hammers
what about the construction field if
people of color
avoid geology because they don't want to
they don't want to risk their lives by
holding objects
what are they doing in construction i
mean in that field white people are
underrepresented
almost 20 of construction workers are
hispanic and 12 percent are black which
is proportional with the general
population if if anyone
was going to be shot for using a hammer
on the job you'd think it'd be a
construction workers who oftentimes are
working in cities and populated areas
not geologists out chipping away at some
limestone in the desert somewhere
but here i am replying a rational
thought to what is wholly irrational
the leftist religion dictates that
everything everywhere must be racist
and it's up to them to you know fill in
the blanks and explain the hows and whys
and in fairness to them it's not easy to
find racism in geology of all things
and this is basically the best they
could do it was an admirable attempt
we must sin but still insane
and for that they are of course today
cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content